En este momento la mejor estimación de cuando
ocurrió el Big Bang -aunque no me gusta tanto el
término porque implica algún tipo de explosión, en
realidad es una expansión del espacio, cuando el
espacio realmente comenzó a expandirse a partir de
una singularidad-, pero nuestra mejor estimación
de cuándo ocurrió esto es de hace 13,700 millones
de años. Y aunque estamos acostumbrados a lidiar
con números de miles de millones, especialmente
cuando hablamos de grandes cantidades de dinero
y otras cosas, ésta es una cantidad de tiempo
increíble, parece algo manejable, pero en realidad
no lo es. Y en futuros videos hablaré sobre la
escala de tiempo para entonces poder darnos cuenta
o comenzar a darnos cuenta de que en realidad no
podemos apreciar cuánto son 13,700 millones de
años. Y también quiero enfatizar que esta es la
mejor estimación hasta el momento, incluso en el
transcurso de mi vida, cuando supe del Big Bang o
la gran explosión y comencé a prestar atención a
cuál era la mejor estimación, este número ha
cambiado, así que sospecho que en el futuro
este número se volverá más exacto o cambiará de
nuevo; pero este es nuestro mejor estimado. Ahora,
dicho esto, quiero que pensemos en lo que esto
nos dice sobre el tamaño del universo observable.
Si la expansión comenzó hace 13,700 millones
de años, todo lo que conocemos en el universo
tridimensional se encontraba en un solo punto,
lo que más ha viajado cualquier fotón de luz y
que nos llega en este momento. Digamos que este es
mi ojo, estas son mis pestañas; si un fotón de luz
llega a mi ojo o al lente de un telescopio, lo más
que ha viajado son 13,700 millones de años, así
que podría haber viajado 13,700 millones de años.
Entonces, cuando vimos aquella representación
-creo que fue hace dos o tres videos- del universo
observable, teníamos este círculo y cuando vemos
luz proveniente de estos objetos remotos esa
luz nos llega justo aquí. Aquí es donde estamos,
y esa luz tardó 13,700 millones de años en llegar
a nosotros. Ahora, como estamos hablando de
distancias enormes y estamos hablando de escalas
de tiempo tan grandes en las que el espacio mismo
se está expandiendo, veremos en este video
que no debemos decir que este objeto de aquí,
este no está -lo pondré en mayúsculas-, esto no
está a 13,700 millones de años luz de distancia.
Si estuviéramos hablando de escalas de distancias
más pequeñas, la expansión del universo en sí
no supondría una gran diferencia. Y permíteme
dejarlo aún más claro: estoy hablando de un objeto
de allí, pero incluso podríamos hablar de esa
coordenada en el espacio, y de hecho debería decir
esa coordenada en el espacio-tiempo porque también
la estamos viendo en un determinado instante. Pero
esa coordenada no está a 13,700 millones de años
luz de nuestra coordenada actual. Y hay un par
de razones para pensar en esto. En primer lugar,
esa luz se emitió hace 13,700 millones de años,
cuando se emitió esa luz estábamos mucho más cerca
de esta coordenada, esta coordenada estaba mucho
más cerca de esta, el lugar en el universo donde
nos encontrábamos en ese instante, estaba mucho
más cerca de ese punto del universo. La otra cosa
en la que debemos pensar. Permíteme dibujarlo.
Imagina que han pasado 300,000 años desde la
expansión inicial de esta singularidad, así que
en este momento el universo tiene 300,000 años de
edad. Supongo que podríamos verlo de esa manera. Y
en primer lugar, en ese momento las cosas aún no
se han diferenciado de una manera significativa.
Hablaremos más de esto cuando veamos la radiación
de microondas cósmica de fondo. Pero en este
momento el universo era una especie de plasma casi
uniforme de hidrógeno candente, luego hablaremos
más al respecto, emitía radiación de microondas,
de lo cual también hablaremos más en detalle en un
futuro video. Pero pensemos en dos puntos en este
joven universo. Digamos que tienes este punto y
digamos que tienes la coordenada donde estamos
ahora. Y, de hecho, no lo pondré en el centro
porque creo que será más sencillo de visualizar
si no está en el centro. Y digamos que en esta
etapa muy temprana del universo, si pudieras medir
esto de forma instantánea, esta distancia mediría
30 millones de años luz, esta distancia mediría
30 millones de años luz. Y digamos que justo en
este punto -este objeto de aquí que dibujaré en
este color-, este objeto de aquí emite un fotón,
tal vez en el rango de frecuencia de microondas, y
veremos que estaba emitiendo en ese rango. Así que
emite un fotón, y ese fotón viaja a la velocidad
de la luz, es luz, y entonces ese fotón dice
"Bueno, sólo tengo que recorrer 30 millones de
años luz, eso no es tan malo; llegaría allí en
30 millones de años". Y voy a hacer esto de forma
discreta, las matemáticas son más complicadas
de lo que estoy haciendo aquí, pero sólo quiero
darles una idea de lo que está pasando. Así que
el fotón dice "Bueno, en unos 10 millones de años
llegaré a esta coordenada más o menos, debería
estar aproximadamente a ⅓ de la distancia". Pero
¿qué sucede en el transcurso de esos 10 millones
de años? Bueno, en el transcurso de esos 10
millones de años el universo se ha expandido
un poco más o quizás se ha expandido mucho más.
Permíteme dibujar el universo expandido. Entonces,
después de 10 millones de años el universo podría
verse así, podría haberse expandido bastante así
que esto es 10 millones de años en el futuro. Y
en una escala de tiempo cosmológica el universo
todavía está en su infancia, porque estamos
hablando de 13,700 millones de años. Entonces,
después de 10 millones de años el universo podría
verse así, podría haberse expandido bastante:
esta coordenada donde estamos ubicados hoy en
este momento ahora está hasta aquí y la coordenada
donde se emitió originalmente el fotón está ahora
ubicada por acá, y ese fotón que dijo "Ok, después
de 10 millones de años luz voy a llegar aquí". Y
es un aproximado; lo hago de una manera discreta
porque sólo quiero darte una idea. Entonces esa
coordenada donde el fotón llega aproximadamente en
10 millones de años luz está por aquí. El universo
entero se ha expandido, todas las coordenadas se
han alejado unas de otras. Ahora, ¿qué acaba
de pasar aquí? El universo se ha expandido:
esta distancia que era de 30 millones de años
luz ahora. Recuerda que estoy aproximando las
cantidades, no conozco los números exactos,
esto es para darte una idea de lo que está
sucediendo. Esta distancia ahora ya no es de 30
millones de años luz, quizás sean 100 millones,
así que ahora están a 100 millones de años luz
de distancia entre sí; el universo se expande,
estas coordenadas, el espacio en realidad, se
está extendiendo. Podrías imaginar que esto es
la superficie de un globo que se está estirando.
Y entonces esta coordenada donde se encuentra
este fotón de luz después de 10 millones de años,
porque ha estado viajando durante 10 millones de
años, en realidad se encuentra a una distancia
mucho mayor, esa distancia ahora podría tal vez
ser más o menos 30 millones de años luz. Y las
matemáticas no son exactas aquí, no he hecho
cálculos para resolverlo. Así que imaginemos
que está a 30 millones de años luz, aunque en
realidad ni siquiera debería hacerlo en la misma
proporción debido a la distancia que ha recorrido
el fotón y la distancia que debe recorrer.
Ahora que el espacio se ha expandido no será
completamente lineal, al menos cuando lo pienso en
mi cabeza no debería serlo, creo, pero no podría
asegurarlo. Quizá la distancia que recorrió ahora
sea de 20 millones de años luz porque cada vez que
recorre cierta distancia el espacio que había
atravesado se había estirado. Entonces, aunque
viajó durante 10 millones de años, el espacio que
atravesó ya no es sólo de 10 millones de años luz,
sino que ahora se extiende a 20 millones de años
luz, y la distancia que le falta por recorrer
ya no es de sólo 20 millones de años luz, ahora
podrían ser 80 millones de años luz. Y es posible
que este fotón se sienta frustrado; aunque hay
una forma optimista de verlo, puede decir "Guau,
pude recorrer 20 millones de años luz en sólo 10
millones de años, parece que me estoy moviendo
más rápido que la velocidad de la luz". Aunque
en realidad esto se debe a que las coordenadas
espaciales se están extendiendo, así que
el fotón se mueve a la velocidad de la luz,
pero la distancia que realmente atravesó en 10
millones de años es más de 10 millones de años
luz, son 20 millones de años luz. Por lo tanto,
no se puede multiplicar una tasa por el tiempo
en estas escalas cosmológicas, especialmente
cuando las coordenadas de distancia misma
se están alejando unas de otras. Pero creo que
puedes ver más o menos hacia dónde va esto. Bien,
este fotón dice "Oh, bueno; si estos son 80
millones de años luz, en otros 40 millones de
años luz tal vez llegaré aquí". Pero la realidad
es que después de 40 millones de años, 40 millones
de años después, ahora el universo se ha expandido
aún más. Ni siquiera dibujaré toda la burbuja,
pero el lugar desde donde se emitió este fotón
podría estar por aquí y ahora nuestra coordenada
actual está aquí, y el lugar donde llegó la luz
después de 10 millones de años está ahora aquí,
y ahora este fotón de luz después de 40 millones
de años tal vez esté por aquí. Por lo que ahora
la distancia entre estos dos puntos, cuando
comenzamos era de 10 millones de años luz,
luego pasó a 20 millones de años luz, quizá ahora
esté en el orden de mil millones de años luz y
tal vez esta distancia aquí. Recuerda que sólo
estoy inventando estos números, y probablemente
sea demasiado grande para este punto. Tal vez esto
sea ahora de 100 millones de años luz, ahora son
100 millones de años luz, y tal vez esta distancia
aquí es de 500 millones de años luz y quizá ahora
la distancia total entre los dos puntos sea de
mil millones de años luz. Seguramente el fotón
podría frustrarse, pues a medida que recorre
más distancia mira hacia atrás y dice "Guau,
en sólo 50 millones de años he podido recorrer 600
millones de años luz; eso es bastante bueno". Pero
está frustrado porque lo que pensaba que tenía
que recorrer en sólo 30 millones de años luz de
distancia sigue extendiéndose, porque el espacio
mismo se sigue expandiendo. Entonces, en realidad,
regresando a la idea original, este fotón que
acaba de llegar a nosotros ha estado viajando,
digamos que ha recorrido 13,400 millones de
años luz, nos está llegando justo ahora. Así que
permíteme avanzar 13,400 millones de años desde
este punto hasta el presente. Entonces, si dibujo
todo el universo visible justo aquí, el fotón
de luz fue emitido en este punto, justo aquí,
nosotros nos encontramos justo acá. Y permíteme
aclarar algo: si estoy dibujando todo el universo
observable, nosotros deberíamos encontrarnos en
el centro, porque podemos observar lo más lejano
a la misma distancia, realmente podemos observar
la misma distancia en cualquier dirección, así que
quizá deba dibujarnos en el centro. Entonces, si
esto fuera todo el universo observable y el fotón
que fue emitido desde aquí hace 13,400 millones de
años, es decir, 300,000 años después del Big Bang,
y apenas está llegando a nosotros, la realidad
es que el fotón ha estado viajando durante 13,400
millones de años. Pero lo que es un poco loco es
que este objeto, ya que al expandirse el universo
nos hemos estado alejando el uno del otro, y según
nuestras mejores estimaciones, este objeto estará
a unos 46,000 millones de años luz de distancia
de nosotros. Y quiero dejarlo muy claro: este
objeto está ahora a 46,000 millones de años luz
de nosotros, y con base en esa luz que ha estado
viajando 13,400 millones de años para alcanzarnos,
la luz es la única forma que tenemos de pensar en
la distancia. Podríamos pensar que tal vez esté
a 13,400 millones de años luz de distancia,
pero la realidad es que, si tuvieras una regla
enorme con la que pudieras medir los años luz en
el espacio en un instante, este espacio aquí se ha
extendido tanto que ahora está a 46,000 millones
de años luz. Y sólo para darte una pista de cuando
hablamos de la radiación de microondas cósmica de
fondo, ¿cómo se verá este punto en el espacio que
en realidad está a 46,000 millones de años luz de
distancia, pero cuyo fotón sólo tardó 13,700
millones de años en llegar a nosotros?, ¿cómo
se verá esto? Nos referimos a los fotones que nos
llegan en este momento; esos fotones salieron hace
13,400 millones de años, entonces esos fotones
son los fotones que se emitieron desde esta
estructura primitiva, desde esta neblina candente
de plasma de hidrógeno. Así que lo que vamos a ver
es esta neblina de plasma candente, un plasma no
diferenciado en átomos estables adecuados, mucho
menos diferenciado en estrellas y galaxias, pero
candente. La realidad actual de este punto en el
espacio que está a 46,000 millones de años luz es
que probablemente ya esté diferenciado en átomos
estables, estrellas, planetas y galaxias. Y,
francamente, si existiera una civilización allí en
este momento y si estuvieran sentados observando
fotones emitidos desde nuestras coordenadas,
desde nuestro punto en el espacio en este momento,
ellos no podrían vernos como estamos actualmente,
sino que nos van a ver como éramos hace 13,400
millones de años, van a ver el estado súper
primitivo de nuestra región del espacio cuando en
realidad era sólo un plasma candente. Y hablaremos
más sobre esto en el próximo video. Pero piénsalo,
cualquier fotón que provenga de ese periodo en
el tiempo, desde cualquier dirección y que haya
estado viajando durante 13,400 millones de años
desde cualquier dirección, vendrá de ese estado
primitivo o se habría emitido cuando el universo
estaba en ese estado primitivo, cuando era sólo
ese plasma candente, esta masa indiferenciada. Y
con suerte esto te dará una idea de dónde proviene
la radiación de microondas cósmica de fondo.